[Musique]
nous sommes le 30 mars 2010 est mon
soirée bienvenue pour le 7-8 les invités
avec et celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité du département est
aujourd'hui le docteur cécile omnes qui
reviendra sur la journée de prévention
du suicide organisé dans son
établissement à plaisir aujourd'hui
comment aider les professionnels c'est
la question à laquelle les spécialistes
ont tenté de répondre soignants
encadrant médecin direction eux aussi
sont victimes et puis michel callot le
président de la fédération française de
cyclisme dévoile son plan à la proche
des jeux de tokyo en 2020 il vient de
tenir une conférence de presse ce matin
au vélodrome de saint quentin en
yvelines
bonsoir docteur naissent d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation la 3e journée
annuelle de prévention du suicide vient
de se tenir dans votre établissement à
plaisir le centre hospitalier
jean-martin-charcot la thématique
retenue est la santé au travail en
établissement de santé
comment aider les professionnels
aujourd'hui en quelques mots il ya une
grande détresse des professionnels de
santé également même si on en parle
finalement assez peu je crains que
l'année dernière et cette année mais
hélas révélé à quel point il existe un
mal-être dans les établissements de
santé dans des contraintes qui sont de
plus en plus importante dans des
logiques d'injonction paradoxale qui
font parfois interrogées même de plus en
plus le sens du travail et des valeurs
que les soignants doivent porter avec
des contraintes que nous partageons avec
les administratifs et les directions
donc c'est vraiment une souffrance
commune et pour lequel la question se
pose de trouver des modalités
d'organisation efficace avant qu'il n'y
ait plus de soignants dans les hôpitaux
parce que eux-mêmes seront trop malade
pour pouvoir effectivement faire leur
travail
la souffrance des soignants s'exprime
sous trois formats pathologies de
surcharge comportementale mentale
organique va pas nécessairement jusqu'au
suicide mais il ya un mal être et
et ça des répercussions sur la santé si
vous constatez oui tout à fait puisqu'il
ya plus d'arrêts maladie il ya plus de
dépressions qui est une maladie mentale
qui se soigne et donc ça désorganise les
services et ceux qui ne sont pas encore
en difficulté se retrouve à porter plus
lourd
voilà enfin c'est comme dans toutes les
entreprises
chaque fois que vous commencez à avoir
une spirale négative qui se met en place
c'est de plus en plus difficile de
pouvoir trouver des bonnes réponses
appropriées
qu'est ce qui explique aujourd'hui cette
situation cette souffrance au travail de
professionnels des professionnels du
personnel de santé
vous avez commencé à l'évoquer il ya des
conditions de travail déjà qu'ils ne
sont pas optimum alors on échappe à la
logique entreprises puisque les hôpitaux
depuis très longtemps maintenant sont
traités comme des entreprises
malgré le fait que les hôpitaux publics
en particulier ont des missions qu'ils
ne peuvent pas remettre en cause donc la
logique entreprise fait que nous avons
les mêmes difficultés que les autres
entreprises en tant que tel et
avec la culpabilité aussi des soignants
qui font qu'ils ont plus de difficulté à
reconnaître leurs propres limites à
reconnaître qu eux-mêmes pourrait
bénéficier de soins alors que il le
préconise à leurs propres patients non
tabou autour de cette question là une
autocensure quelque part aussi une
autocensure je sais pas si c'est un
tabou puisqu'on en parle de plus en plus
c'est que notre ministre de la santé a
pris la mesure de la situation et il ya
déjà une dynamique qui est en cours au
plus haut niveau après la réalité c'est
que c'est difficile effectivement pour
les soignants quel qu'il soit de se
reconnaître eux mêmes comme malade et
donc possiblement défaillant et il ya un
retard aux soins avoir une absence de
consultation qui est péjoratif pour eux
je vais donner quelques chiffres 50 %
des professionnels de santé qui sont
bons et et en burn-out taux de suicide
chez les médecins
deux fois et demie supérieur à la
moyenne nationale chez les 30 65 ans là
aussi vous l'avez évoqué rapidement tout
à l'heure mais une inquiétude
aujourd'hui autour de autour des
professions autour de l'avenir des
métiers de santé tout simplement pour
exercer sa profession
oui il ya eu une profonde mutation des
pratiques de métier de façon générale et
la santé nih n'y coupe pas il y a quand
même même si le nombre de médecins en
france est tout à fait suffisant il y à
un défaut de médecins sur le terrain
dans les postes les plus difficiles et
et cette souffrance se ressemblent de
plus en plus il faut pouvoir penser la
santé autrement l'organisation de santé
autrement et pas uniquement dans une
logique financière qui est celle qui est
tenu dans le discours
après on est d'accord que ce n'est pas
la seule qui prévaut mais c'est celle
que l'on entend le plus et qui fait que
le sens même du travail au jour
d'aujourd'hui y compris dans les
professions de santé se perd de plus en
plus aujourd'hui passé le constat
quelles sont les préconisations et les
pistes éventuelles que vous pouvez
explorer pour améliorer la situation
la première piste est de savoir que ça
existe et d'en tenir compte
après comme dans toute entreprise qui
est une volonté commune partagée avec la
direction dans un climat de confiance de
façon à pouvoir construire ensemble un
bilan partagé objectif est derrière
dégager des solutions permettant de re
situer les pratiques qu'il faut
préserver les choses qu'il faut revoir
quel bien-être peut-on penser aussi pour
les travailleurs et pas uniquement pour
les usagers parce que effectivement au
jour d'aujourd'hui tout est centré sur
l'usagé du système de soins ce qui est
tout à fait légitime mais il ne faut pas
que ce soit au détriment des
professionnels de santé
sans rentrer dans des considérations
politiques vous avez le sentiment que
les différents programmes qui sont
avancés par les candidats aujourd'hui
répondent aussi d'une certaine manière à
toutes vos attentes
qu'est-ce qu'on vous prend en
considération parce qu on entend aussi
parler cette réduction du personnel
globale aussi dans les établissements
hospitaliers on demande de travailler
plus travailler plus avec moins est une
logique qu'on entend depuis très
longtemps après les programmes sont ce
qu'ils sont les promesses n'engagent que
ceux qui les écoutent
donc je travaillerai avec les réalités
non justement pour travailler avec les
réalités ya eu ce plan en 2016 lancée
par marisol touraine la ministre de la
santé plan d'action 30 millions d'euros
consacrés sur trois ans au déploiement
de services de santé au travail
ça aide à quelque chose la réalité c'est
que nous n'avons plus de médecins du
travail
donc de toute façon il va falloir penser
autrement la santé au travail
les psychologues du travail sont
absolument essentielles ils ont une
place majeure ce ne sont pas les seules
personnes pouvant effectivement porter
les réalités il faut pouvoir penser
autrement on est passé au 21e
siècle il faut faire une médecine et il
faut faire une santé du 21ème ça veut
dire qu'il faut tout revoir aujourd'hui
il faut déjà savoir qu'est ce qu'il faut
garder avant de savoir effectivement ce
qu'il faut modifier ce qui est sûr aussi
c'est que le numérique et la
communication virtuelle a profondément
modifié les pratiques
il faut revenir au lien social il faut
rompre les solitudes et les isolements
de chacun des professionnels
il faut revoir les logiques de travail
il faut revoir la possibilité de
travailler ensemble et d'avoir envie d'y
aller avec le sourire et pas avec la
peur au ventre parce qu'on sait pas ce
qu'on va trouver et qu'on sait pas si on
va pouvoir faire notre travail
correctement ce jour là merci docteur en
s d'être venu en plateau je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui se déroulait la troisième
journée annuelle de prévention du
suicide dans votre établissement à
plaisir le centre hospitalier
jean-martin-charcot il vous avez évoqué
cette problématique finalement assez peu
abordée dès que rencontre le personnel
soignant également victimes de ces
difficultés merci donc de 7,8 invités se
poursuit on va parler de sport à présent
[Musique]
michel callot c'est le nouveau président
de la fédération française de cyclisme
depuis le 11 mars dernier il vient de
tenir un premier point presse ce matin
un point presse pour évoquer l ses
priorités pour son mandat et notamment
des enjeux importants at-elle que les
prochaines olympiades de 2020 à tokyo
alors je suis avec michel caillaud le
nouveau président de la fédération
française de cyclisme
alors michel cailleau comment se sont
passés ces derniers jours depuis votre
nomination
écoutez c'est un travail je suis
effectivement beaucoup de travail dans
un premier temps c'est normal il faut
découvrir l'ensemble des dossiers il
faut découvrir également l'ensemble des
personnes qui travaillent pour la
fédération donc j'ai pris beaucoup de
temps à essayer d'échanger avec chacun
imprégné mieux possible de l'intérieur
on va dire de cette fédération même si
je la connais quand même très bien en
tant qu'élu depuis maintenant plusieurs
mandats au sein de conseils nutrition et
puis du conseil fédéral pour récupérer
une fédération en bon état où il ya du
travail
oui la fédération française de cyclisme
est une d'abord une fédération qui a
pignon sur rue qui est réinstallé dans
le panorama du sport français
mais naturellement les choses ont bougé
dans cette opération l'installation ici
où notre homme de 50 a cédé sujet pas
simple quand même
et comme vous le dites il ya du travail
il ya des choses à faire pour pour
l'avenir et pour faire progresser notre
sport il ya un sujet un petit peu
épineux on peut le dire la nomination du
nouveau dtn vincent jacquet a été
écartée pourquoi ce choix alors comme
comme je les ai exprimé samedi dernier
vincent jacquet est un un dtn qui a
beaucoup de qualités d'investissement de
travail simplement entre un président et
un dtn il faut être en parfait accord
sur la manière d'animer le projet
sportif et avec vincent jacquet
on a fait le constat qu'on avait ses
difficultés à trouver cet accord et j'ai
donc maintenant à faire le choix d'un
nouveau dtn et du coup le nouveau dtn
quelle qualité doit-il de t'avoir alors
le nouveau dtn
d'abord nous avons une première qualité
c'est c'est une capacité à bien
connaître l'activité de haut niveau d
activité de haut niveau en matière de
cyclisme et je souhaite un dtn qu'ils
soient issus du haut niveau quelqu'un
qui aura eu une pratique sportive de
haut niveau me semble indispensable
ensuite le dtn aujourd'hui dans un
contexte où depuis l'opération française
cyclisme ça doit être un manager il a
une équipe assez importante
il faut ses qualités de management et
puis parce que je souhaite qu'on soit
tout à fait en phase avec le dtn j'ai
besoin que ce soit quelqu'un un homme de
dialogue
quelqu'un avec qui on soit en phase sur
l'idée que c'est par la conservation ont
fait avancer les projets notamment à
l'échelle d'une fédération il faut
décliner sur tous les territoires en
plus d'un dtn vous êtes à la recherche
d'un sélectionneur
alors oui il se trouve qu'en plus il se
trouve effectivement que bernard
bourreau a arrêté un sa mission de
sélectionneur après les derniers
championnats du monde professionnels
donc la démarche là de recrutement est
en cours
on a reçu onze candidatures et là c'est
un choix que
je ferai en étroite collaboration avec
le président de la ligue nationale de
cyclisme
marc madiot vous allez centralisée est
vraiment toutes les disciplines les
élites et les jeunes ici vous verrez
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ou pas c'est
un projet en tout cas l'étude alors est
ce qui est certain c'est que on a a
profité à faire profiter à nos sportifs
le mieux possible de cet équipement
assez extraordinaire notamment avec tout
les sites où les apports qui ont pu être
faits en terme de salle de musculation
de récupération pour les athlètes
on a un outil qui est juste remarquable
on a la possibilité depuis ceux ci de
faire du vtt de faire de la route de
faire du bmx bien sûr avec le stadium de
bmx évidemment de la piste donc il faut
que dans notre projet sportif on trouve
le moyen de de faire profiter ses biens
le long terme à nos athlètes le mieux
possible de ce site et la fédération
française et dc auxi à saint quentin en
yvelines et rations à son siège ici ce
qui est ce qui est en plus très pratique
ça faciliterait justement le dialogue
entre les jeunes les élites la
fédération un élément de cohésion il
faut le faire vivre et c'est pour ça que
pour pour le président de l'opération
que je suis c'est extrêmement important
d'être au coeur du projet sportif et
d'en partager l'animation avec sont
déterrés est ce que vous vous êtes fixé
des objectifs en terme de médailles de
titres sur les prochaines années on sait
qu'il ya les prochains jeux olympiques
sont déjà enclenchées pour le cyclisme
sur piste notamment
est ce que vous êtes fixé cet objectif
de médailles alors c'est un petit peu
tôt pour se fixer des objectifs de
médaille je souhaite d'abord on soit
dans la construction de notre projet
sportif dans la construction de la
structuration qui est à mettre en place
autour de notre projet sportif et puis
en temps voulu on fixera effectivement
des objectifs qui exprimeront réellement
l'ambition du cyclisme français
par contre sur un autre plan que les
jeux olympiques
concernant les coureurs professionnels
clairement on doit se fixer l'objectif
dans cette olympiade d'aller à la
conquête d'un titre mondial de cyclisme
sur route parce que nos athlètes dont le
potentiel derrière question est ce que
vous pouvez rassurer les fans de
cyclisme qui nous regarde en ce moment
sur tf1 78 la caméra juste là oui bien
sûr bien sûr je peux les rassurer sur un
point précis
tous peuvent compter sur ma
détermination ma détermination elle sera
présente pour faire en sorte que la
fédération soit un outil le plus utile
possible tous ses adhérents
c'est déjà un point important que la
fédération se développe auprès d'un
nouveau public
et puis également et c'est pas le moins
que la fédération amène ses athlètes à
performer au plus haut niveau et bien
évidemment dans les plus grandes
compétitions mondiales et olympiques
merci messieurs les caillots et bon
courage merci à vous c'est la fin de
cette suite les invités qui reviendra
donc lundi pour faire un nouveau point
avec ceux qui représentent le head
département très belle soirée sur notre
antenne
[Musique]